I feel like it's different because money
is to come listen money is the commodity
that's needed that there's no choice in
that one in it I'm not doing a break man
because I'm sorry no no but historically
like they're attracted to good genes
that's what's needed exactly oh you're
gonna say the hips argument that no I'm
not a woman it's not actually no I
wasn't talking about the hips argument I
was saying men are biologically
predispositioned to like thinner women
why because they're it's better genes
it's better Offspring if a woman's
overweight her chance of an unhealthy
pregnancy is higher which I think is is
common sense right if you're out of
shape and you're unhealthy like odds are
a man say that's the reason well it's
not it's not a conscious I don't think
it's always a conscious thing with men
some for some men it is right right but
they can't help but they're biologically
attracted to the same way they can't
help if they're attracted to a girl with
a lower body count